(wind whooshing)
(dramatic music)
(pickaxe clanking)
(dramatic music continuing)
(dog whimpering)
(pickaxe clanking)
(Aatami yelling)
(dog barking)
(dramatic music continuing)
- Get off the horse.
(horse neighing)
This old fucker is a gold miner.
We're rich boys!
(dog barking)
- Get down on your knees.
- [Nazi] Fuck him up!
(laughing)
- We got gold!
(knife singing)
(body thudding)
(soldier grunting)
(gun chattering)
(Aatami grunting)
(intense music)
- [Wolf] He was a Finnish
commander.
Lost his home and his family in
the war.
♪ Ho ♪
He became a one man death squad.
(soldier yelling)
(engine revving)
(gun chattering)
- He's one mean mother fucker
that you do not want to mess
with.
(landmine whooshing)
- [Helldorf] Fire!
(guns chattering)
(dramatic music)
- You'll see what happens when
you take everything from him.
(Aatami yelling)
(gun chattering)
- Do you really believe that
he's immortal?
- [Aino] No, he just refuses to
die.
- How many mines did you bury
here?
- All of them.
- You, and you.
(dramatic music)
(mine whooshing)
(leg whooshing)
(dramatic music continuing)
(Nazi yelling)
- This is not about who's the
strongest.
This is about not giving up.
(bike whirring)
We have a word for that in
Finland.
(Aatami yelling)
- [Narrator] Sisu!
(dramatic music continuing)
- We might have a problem.
♪ Ho ♪